Other property attributes you may want
to include between these parentheses
include readwrite, readonly, and copy.
Notice that for the House class
we declared our properties in
the header file, the public interface.
So right now,
if I go into the main function, notice
that I'm outside of the House class.
But I can get a hold of
an instance of House and
change its number of bedrooms for
example.
Let's say we wanted
to limit that access.
We could start by declaring number of
bedrooms in the implementation file so
that it's private.
So we switch over to the .m file and
and we redeclare number of bedrooms.
And we marked this private
implementation with the property
attribute readwrite.
Readwrite means what it sounds like.
>From inside the class, one can read or
write to this variable.
Then we switch back to the .h file and
we mark this version of
the property as readonly.
Naturally, read only means that one
can read the value of the property but
not write to it.
Notice that if I go back
to the main function,
I can access the number of
bedrooms from outside the class.
But I don't have to worry about
accidentally changing it.
If I try to write to this property,
the compiler won't allow it.
You can think of readwrite and
readonly as being similar to var and
lap in Swift.
Readwrite is akin to defining
something as a variable and
readonly is akin to defining
something as a constant.
Since our address
property is an NSString,
we're going to want to mark it
with the property attribute copy.
In general,
you want to use copy for strings.
To understand why,
let's see what happens when we
don't mark the address with copy.
Here we are in the main function
of the House class, and
in this line we're creating
a string that's holding an address.
Now we're going to use that address to
initialize an instance of the House
class, myHouse.
If we log the address of myHouse to
the console, we see 555 Park Ave.
Cool, now let's say some joker
is writing test code and
they append this string La la Land
to the addressString variable.
Notice that we never accessed
myHouse.address a second time?
But if we log the current value of
myHouse.address to the console,
we see 555 Park Ave., La La Land.
So that's no good.
We don't want to leave properties
of our classes vulnerable to
unintentional changes.
Right now,
we're initializing the address property
with a pointer to addressString.
We can fix this problem by initializing
the address property with its
own independent copy of addressString.
So we'll go back to our house.h file,
we'll mark address with copy,
and then run the program again.
You can see that this time the value
of myHouse.address doesn't change.